NAZMUL IDRIS: Hi everyone, and
welcome to "UX Design for
Developers." My name is Nazmul,
and I'm a developer.
IZABEL IDRIS: And I'm Izabel,
and I'm a designer.
NAZMUL IDRIS: In the first
episode of the show, we
provided you with a brief
overview of the user centric
design process, and why it's
important for developers to
understand.
But we really didn't spend too
much time going over any
specific details.
So in this episode, we're going
to actually use the
process, and go through it in
a pretty good amount of
detail, to actually show
you how we can
better design products.
We're going to continue using
the example of building a
mobile pizza ordering
application to illustrate how
this process works.
The mobile pizza ordering
application is a good example,
since everybody's familiar
with ordering pizza, and
everybody loves it.
And it also allows us to
highlight the process, rather
than the product.
So you can use this process to
build any type of product,
whether it's something physical,
or an API, or an
application.
So to get started, let's imagine
that we have a startup
that creates local, artisanal
pizza and sells it online.
And we also have a
retail presence.
Now let's say that our goal is
to use technology to deliver a
better pizza experience for
our discerning users.
And that includes ordering pizza
and, also, the actual
ingredients of the
pizza, and so on.
So I'm going to, now, switch to
the slides and show you the
four steps that we're going to
follow to enable our startup
to create an application with
a really amazing user
experience.
So the very first thing we need
to ask ourselves is, what
is the goal.
Why are we doing this?
Why are we building
this application?
Why is our startup doing
what it does?
So setting business goals early
on, and defining success
metrics for whatever product it
is that we're building, is
really, really important.
So once we have an idea of why
we're doing what we're doing,
the second step is everybody
talks about satisfying users.
So who is our user?
We have to understand
who our users
are by creating personas.
So once we have an understanding
of our users,
the next thing we have to do
is ask how these users are
going to use our application
in different scenarios.
And those are called
use casees.
So we're going to go through
and actually
create a bunch of those.
And finally, we're going to take
features, which we're all
used to as developers.
And then, we're going to frame
the features in the context of
use cases and personas and then
make sure they tie back
into the original goals that
we have already defined.
And then, when we finally
integrate all these pieces, we
will have a much, much better
designed, solid, holistic type
of a product.
Now what we're not going to talk
about is UI specifics, or
which mobile platform,
like Android or iOS,
we're going to use.
Because we're in a really
early stage in design.
And those types of discussions
should really be tabled for a
later time, when we have the
personas and the use cases
better scoped out.
So now, how do we define the
goals of this project?
At the start of the project, we
should just think about why
we're building an application
for our startup, instead of
really focusing on the what.
As developers, we tend to really
fixate on features and
how features are going
to be implemented.
So we have to have some
discipline and actually back
away from that and just
focus on the why.
Now, let's ask questions.
The following questions,
actually,
will help you identify--
will help us identify--
why we're doing this.
So why are we building
this application?
What problems will it
solve for our users?
And how will it improve on any
pre-existing solutions?
And finally, what is
our special sauce?
What do we do better than our
competitors, and what makes us
really unique?
So now if we go back to the
slides, this slide actually
talks about the goal.
So we're going to go through
and answer some of those
questions I just asked and
basically come up with a
specific set of goals that our
business and our product has
to deliver.
So first of all, why are we
building this application?
We're building this application
to satisfy users
who are hungry for pizza.
So it's important not to get
derailed by strong opinions
from individuals in sales, PM,
or leadership and lose
perspective of this.
Sometimes, applications seem
like they're built in the
service of certain buzzwords
that your
investors might be into.
But that's not a
very good idea.
So every design decision that
we make should be in the
service of the user.
Another thing to keep in mind is
that we have to understand
what is important to users when
they're ordering pizza.
So dietary restrictions
come into play.
People care about convenient
delivery windows.
People care about quality
versus price.
People care about the ease
of ordering versus
customizability.
And of course, people care that
it should be easy to pay.
So those are all parts of the
goals that we're assembling,
that we're going to actually use
to evaluate our design in
this episode.
And one last thing is an
abstract kind of a goal.
And that is, what is
our special sauce.
So our special sauce for this
made up startup is the
following-- we support
local farmers.
We use sustainable
ingredients.
And we use sustainable business
practices to create pizza.
And we enable our users to
feel connected to their
community, and make them feel
good when they do business
with us, because they're
giving back
to their local community.
Again these are very,
very nontechnical,
pretty abstract goals.
But by the end of this episode,
you'll see how we can
actually tie that to features.
Now design has to be in the
service of our business, as
well as our end users.
So aside from great-tasting
pizza and easy ordering via
our mobile application, this
personal connection to our
business will keep customers
coming back.
The user centric design process
serves to remind us
that we're designing for people
who make decisions
based on emotion.
So abstract goals like this can
be our special sauce that
delivers delight to our
intended audience.
However, it has to be
weaved into our
product using good design.
So Izabel, now that I'm done
talking about goals, do you
want to talk a little
bit about personas?
IZABEL IDRIS: Yeah, sure.
So now that we have our goals
outlined, let's talk about who
the user is.
We often hear people say, we
need to make design decisions
and development decisions
that are in
service of our end user.
So who is this user?
There is no real, one user.
Instead of users, we're going
to think about personas.
So personas are conceptual
models that represent the
demographics, the attributes,
and the pain points of a
certain segment of
a population--
of the pizza-eating population,
in our example.
So we really need to choose
personas that represent our
business goals.
And then, we're going to
optimize our user experience
based on these personas,
moving forward.
So what are some examples
of real people in this
pizza-eating population that
I'm just talking about?
Some people will eat anything.
And then, other people have
dietary restrictions.
Some people think pizza should
be healthy, and other people
think pizza is just junk food
that you order when you don't
have time to cook.
Some people spend a lot of
money on pizza, and some
people are completely
value-conscious, and they just
want it as cheap as possible.
Some people expect to order
pizza over the phone and then
have it delivered
and pay cash.
And then, other people want a
really seamless ordering flow,
an automated approach.
So let's say that's some
information about our pizza
eating population.
So as a startup, which one of
these-- what part of this
population--
are we going to support?
How do we turn that population
into an actual persona?
So we would want to support
people who think that pizza
should be healthy.
Why?
Because our startup focuses on
quality, local ingredients.
So we want to focus on people
who spend a good bit of money
on pizza, because one of our
goals is for our startup to
support local farmers and local
community, and not to outsource.
We would also want to support
people who want a seamless,
automated approach, because
the whole point is we're
building a mobile app.
And we want to use technology to
really facilitate a better
ordering experience.
So based on that population,
or that demographics
information, those are
some people that
would make up our personas.
So personas really serve to
help us during the entire
product development
life cycle.
It helps us with things like
this-- we can prioritize user
stories in our backlog and
answer the question, would it
be more important to implement
feature A, or feature B. So we
look back at our personas.
And then, that can help us
decide, OK, we should
implement this user
story first.
It can also help us identify
corner cases that can waste a
lot of time.
So we can answer the question,
would 95% of our users
actually use the feature in this
way, or is this going to
be something that just 1%
of the users would use.
And also, one of the more
intangible things is it can
really help remind us, as
developers, why we're here,
why we're coding, during
really long sprints.
So when we reference the
personas' attributes, and
their pain points, it really
puts a human context around
what we're all doing here.
So let's take a moment and
look at the slides.
We're going to go through
a few personas.
We're going to use the user
centric design process.
This is one persona
for our startup.
So let's take a minute, and
look at Casey Smith.
Her tagline is "Give me control,
healthy options, and
quality."
So if you notice,
Casey Smith--
she shops on Amazon.
So she's already an
online shopper.
She's pretty educated
and tech savvy.
And she likes to use
Google Wallet.
So we can tell that a seamless
checkout experience would be
really important for her.
And of course, she values
high quality pizza.
So now we're going to go to our
second persona, which is
Sally, Sally Jones.
And her tagline is "Save me
time, surprise me with
something new." So let's take a
minute and look over Sally.
We can tell she's also educated
and tech savvy.
And she shops at the farmers
market weekly.
So she likes local, artisanal
ingredients.
She likes social networking.
And she also likes high quality,
healthy pizza.
We're going to go to the third
persona, which is Bob Brown.
His tagline is "Save me money,
and keep it old skool." So
let's take a moment to look
over his persona.
So we can see that Bob prefers
to pay with cash on delivery.
And he rarely shops online.
And he's a value shopper
that wishes
pizza wasn't so expensive.
So I think it would make sense
to support Casey and Sally,
but to drop Bob as a
persona that our
startup should support.
Because his persona
really doesn't fit
our business goals.
And if we tried to optimize a
user experience that supported
Casey and Sally, it probably
wouldn't be a good
experience for Bob.
And if we tried to create a
user experience that would
really work for all three of
them, it would be good for
none of them.
So it's really important that
we select the right personas
from the very beginning, before
we start any design or
any development.
So we can remove any
the wrong personas.
And we can't satisfy
everybody.
All right, so now, I'm going
to talk a little
bit about use cases.
Use cases are the scenarios that
describe the when, the
where, and the how that Casey
and Sally are going to use our
app to order pizza.
So from use cases, we can
actually start and build our
feature list.
So when we think of use cases,
think about the different
physical, social, and emotional
contexts that our
personas are going to be in when
they order pizza, to go
from being hungry to
being satisfied.
So now we're going to go back to
the slides, and we're going
to look at our first use case.
So the use case for Sally--
we're going to look at the
when, where, and the how.
So let's just take a moment
to look at the slide.
So basically, Casey prefers
to pay with credit card.
And she's kind of
a picky eater.
And she places her
order from home.
So we're just going to go to the
second use case for Sally
and just take a moment
to look over that.
So this is the use case for her
placing a group order for
friends while she's at home.
So she likes to use carrier
billing to place this order.
And she doesn't really have
any dietary restrictions,
because she likes all kinds
of different ingredients.
So we're going to go to
a third use case.
And this is also for Sally.
So this is when Sally
would be at work.
And she wants to order about
30 pizzas or so.
And it's going to be for
all of her coworkers.
And all of them want to pay
differently, and they want to
check out differently, and they
want to really customize
this huge order.
So I would recommend that we
remove use case number three,
because it doesn't support
our business goals.
So one of our business goals
was to balance the ease of
ordering and the
customizability.
So if you think, how would I
build a flow, how would the
screens actually look in order
to build this application.
So if we were to support use
case number three, it would be
really difficult to support the
first two use cases and
balance ease of ordering and
customizability because it
would be very difficult to
support all of these multiple
checkout and payment forms.
And also, use case number three
really doesn't support
one of our goals, which
is to feel connected
to our local community.
So now I'm going to move over
to give it over to Nazmul.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thank you.
So now that we have our personas
and use cases sorted
out, it's time to tie
features to them.
Now one of those abstract,
non-technical goals that we
had was that we wanted to
support local farmers, use
sustainable ingredients
and business
practices to create pizza.
And also we wanted to allow this
application to connect
users with their community.
So how on earth do we take these
abstract goals and tie
them to technology and features
that fit the use
cases and personas that we've
actually outlined so far?
One example of doing this would
be to gamify the menu.
That means that when a user is
assembling their pizza, and
they're selecting different
ingredients, we could have a
little score, from one to
five, that grades each
ingredient based on the
localness or the
sustainability.
So for example, if you have a
lot of ingredients that score
really highly on sustainability,
then, when you
assemble your order, you will
have an order that ranks
really high-- it gets a really
high sustainability score.
So this really encourages a user
that's into this sort of
thing to pick seasonal
ingredients over less
sustainable choices that
they might actually
desire at the moment.
So it's important to surface
this information in the user
experience so that
it can help the
user better make decisions.
So once they've assembled their
order, and they have a
score, and it's a pretty good
score, then they might want to
brag about it.
So then, we can enable this
order to be shared on the
Google+ platform.
So we can do this by simply
taking the order, with the
score, and just sharing it.
We can share that as a link,
and it'll show up in the
user's friends stream.
So let's say I create order, I
have a sustainability score of
four or something.
I can just share it
to my stream.
And then, everybody in my circle
will actually see that.
Now let's say I wanted to take
it to the next level.
I wanted to provide some
engagement and interaction
beyond just an image or
a link that's shared.
What I could actually do is
create a web application that
behaves as an interactive
infographic that I can
actually, basically create,
let's say, an order ID for
this order.
And then I can pass that, as a
deep link, to something called
the Google+ interactive post.
So from my mobile application,
I've created the order, I've
placed it, I have a score, I
want to share the order.
I actually create an
interactive post.
And what that does is,
I take that order ID.
I pass it to Google+, which
generates an interactive post,
which shows up on--
all the friends I have
in my circles--
it shows up in their stream.
And then, when it's rendered
in their stream, it says
something like, Nazmul
shared this order.
Here's his sustainability
score.
And then, click on this button
if you want to learn more
about sustainability, and how
his order ranks amongst other
people who have placed orders
in the local area.
So it almost turns into an
interactive kind of a game,
but you're getting more
information out of it.
So we are engaging other users
and making it so that I'm not
just bragging about my score.
But they're also getting an
opportunity to learn more
about who else cares about
sustainability in their local
region and also, how they're
making an impact, how they're
actually being more sustainable,
and connecting
with their community, by
encouraging other people to
learn more about businesses,
for example, that were all
about sustainability, that they
wouldn't have even known
about, if I hadn't shared
that infographic.
IZABEL IDRIS: So your business
basically allows the users to
connect with their
local community.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly
IZABEL IDRIS: And they're going
to appreciate that.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah, exactly.
And also, it puts sort of a
new spin on ordering food,
because it encourages
participation from my friends.
So it's like, I create
an order.
You see it.
You're inspired by that.
You're like, oh, I can
beat that score.
So then, you create
another order.
And then, we all kind
of get into it.
And then, as a community, we can
all get fat eating pizza,
but really healthy pizza, and
also giving back to the
community, while we're gorging
ourselves on pizza.
IZABEL IDRIS: And of course,
it'd be great way to spread
the word about your business.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
IZABEL IDRIS: It's kind of viral
marketing, through G+.
NAZMUL IDRIS: It is, exactly.
And also, even if I wasn't
interested about pizza, let's
say some random person is
looking at my public posts.
And then, let's say I shared
this as a public post.
Then, they'll run across
this infographic thing.
They might start engaging
with that.
And then, just through this
random infographic about
sustainability on how
sustainable my pizza is, in
Mountain View, they start
learning about this business.
They start learning about
sustainable farming and all
this good stuff.
So anyway, all this, put
together, creates an
experience that connects our
user with their community and
also creates opportunities to
get new users engaged in
product and business, which
was our stated goal at the
beginning of the show.
And so this illustrates how,
again, we take the design
process, and how these seemingly
nontechnical,
abstract goals can end up
becoming one of the most
important, compelling
differentiators--
the most important things that
resonate with the user when
they actually interact
with our application.
And in this example, because
we have a startup that also
has a retail outlet, we would
hope that this thinking, and
this design thinking around
sustainability, would also
reflect in we actually operated
the retail stores--
which, obviously, we're not
going to get into for this
particular episode.
So before we wrap up, I
actually had one final
question for you.
As a designer, where do you see
companies skipping one of
these steps, or more than one
of these steps, in the user
centric design process?
Where do they go wrong in
following the process?
IZABEL IDRIS: I think the most
important step that companies
are skipping is the first
one, the goal setting.
This needs to really come from
the leadership of the company.
They need to set the goals for
what their company and what
their product stands for.
They need to define their
special sauce.
And from there, each of the
product teams can actually
define their personas
and use cases.
And I think that product
managers, developers, and
designers are all looking for
that from leadership.
And if they don't have that,
it's really hard for them to
know where to start from.
I personally believe that most
companies can build much
better products than they do.
They just really need to take
the time to ponder on and
define and really express
their uniqueness.
And this might sound a little
bit touchy-feely or designery,
but we really need to remember
that, in the end of the day,
we're building products
for people.
And people make emotional
based decisions.
NAZMUL IDRIS: So essentially,
to summarize--
if you don't care about what
you're building, then that
shows through.
And users can tell.
IZABEL IDRIS: Yep.
If you don't care about what
you're building, your users
are going to be able
to feel that.
There's really no way
to fake that.
So I'm going to leave you guys
with a quick little exercise,
once you're done watching
the video.
Maybe take the time to think
about the product, or the
feature, that you're
implementing right now.
And do you think that it maps
back to your personas and the
use cases that have
been defined?
And if you're not sure what
those personas and use cases
are, check with your designers,
or your product
managers, and see if you can
get a hold of those.
So we're actually going to
create a post on our G+
community for this episode.
And feel free to leave comments
on that post.
And let us know how you did, and
maybe, what you learned.
And I think that's it.
And we're going to wrap up.
And thanks for watching this
episode of "UX Design for
Developers."
NAZMUL IDRIS: And remember,
design is everyone's
responsibility.